now if you look forward to what's going
to happen over upcoming years is the
hardware for these applications for
running your own that's really really
quickly are going to get fast faster
than people expect and I think that what
that's gonna unlock is they're going to
be able to scale up these models and
you're going to see qualitatively
different behaviors from what you've
seen so far I'm at opening I we see this
sometimes for example we had a paper on
this I unsupervised learning where you
train a language model to train a model
to predict the next character in Amazon
reviews and just by learning to predict
the next character and Amazon reviews
some somehow it learned a
state-of-the-art sentiment analysis
classifier and so it's kind of crazy if
you think about it right you just were
told hey predict the next character and
you know if you were told to do this
well the first thing you do is you'd
learn the spelling of words and you
learned punctuation the next thing you
do you start to learn semantics right if
you have actual capacity there and that
this effect goes away if you use a
slightly smaller model and what happens
if you have a slightly larger model what
we don't know because we can't run those
models yet mmm but in upcoming years
we'll be able to what do you guys think
are the most promising under explored
areas in AI if we're trying to make it
come faster what should people be
working on that they're not yeah so many
areas of AI that we already developed by
quite a bit there is there's some some
basic research in just classification
deplaning getting reinforcement learning
and what people do is people kind of try
to invent problems and the such as
solving some complicated games of
karakia structure and they try to add
kind of extra features to their models
to combat those problems but I think
there is very little research happening
on actually understanding the existing
methods and their limits so so for
example it was a long-held belief in
defining that kind of to paralyze the to
paralyze your computation you need to
cram as small batches as possible on
every on every device and in fact Baidu
did this impressive engineering feat
where they
took recurrent neural networks and they
implement that that kind of GPU assembly
code to make sure that you can fit like
bat size one adenines on average appear
and you know it despite like all the
smart people working on this problem is
like only very recently the Facebook
kind of took a called quiet look at just
like very basic problem of
classification and they in their great
effort called image that it one hour
they showed that if you actually take a
code that does image classification and
if you fix all the bugs you actually can
get away with much much about size and
therefore finish the classification
probably much faster and you know it's
not the kind of sexy research that
people want to see you I already have
like some er [ __ ] the Adhan and but but
it actually this kind of research I
think at this point will advance field
the most so Greg you mentioned hardware
and your initial answer in the near term
what are the actual like innovations
that you foresee happening um so the big
change is that I the kinds of computers
that we've been trying to make really
fast
our general-purpose computers that are
built on the bottom in architecture you
know basically processor you have a big
memory and you know if you have some
some some bottleneck between the two
with the applications that we're
starting to do now suddenly you can
start making use of massively parallel
compute that the architectures that
these models can run on sort of the
fastest are going to look kind of like
the brain where you know the brain is
basically you have a bunch of neurons
that all have their own memory right
near to them and that they all talk to
their neighbors and maybe there's some
kind of longer range skip connections
and that just no one's really had an
incentive to develop hardware like this
and so what we've seen is that well you
move your neural networks from running
on a CPU to GPU and now suddenly you
have thousand CUDA cores running in
parallel and that you can get massive
performance boost there now if you move
to specialized hardware that is sort of
much more brain like and that runs a
bunch of you know the sort of runs in
parallel with
bunch of tiny little cores that you're
going to be able to run these models
sort of insanely faster okay so I think
one of the most common questions or
threads of question that were asked on
Twitter and Facebook were generally how
to get into AI could you guys give us
just a primer of where someone should
start if they're you know just a CS
major in college yeah absolutely so it
really depends on the nature of the
project that you would like to do I can
tell you a bit about our project which
is essentially developing large-scale
reinforcement learning for dota 2 and
their majority of the work is actually
engineering and you know like
essentially taking you know taking
taking the algorithms that we have
already implemented and trying to scale
them up it's usually the usually the
fastest way to get improvement in in in
our experiments so so essentially
becoming a good engineer for our team is
much more valuable than for example
people spending you know most of almost
implementing exotic models in terms of
flow so just to echo this because it I
hear this come up all the time it's like
my dream to work at open eye but I gotta
go get an AI PhD so I'll see you in like
five or seven years if people are just a
really solid engineer but no experience
at all with AI how long does it take
someone like that to become productive
for the kind of work at opening I that
we that we're looking for so someone
like that can actually become productive
from day one and that there's I with
different engineers who show up and open
the eyes if there's a spectrum of where
they went where they end up specializing
there are some people who focus on
building out infrastructure and that
that actually this infrastructure can
range from well we have a big kubernetes
deployment that we run on top of of you
know cloud platform and building pooling
and monitoring and sort of managing this
this underlying layer and actually looks
quite a bit like running a startup and
that a lot of people who are most
successful at that have quite a bit
of you know running that large scale in
a start-up or production environment
there's kind of a next level of getting
closer to the actual machine learning
where if you think of how machine
learning systems look that they tend to
be this like magical black box of
machine learning that this list core and
you actually trying to make that core be
as small as possible because machine
learning is really hard eats a lot of
compute it's really hard to tell what's
going on there and so you want it to be
as simple as possible but then you
surround it by as much engineering as
you possibly can so what what percent of
the work on the dota2 project would you
guys say was what people would really
think of as like machine learning
science versus engineering essentially
like as far as day-to-day work goes the
this kind of work was almost
non-existent those like might be few
person weeks spend on that I compared to
like person mouse friend to engineering
and I think maybe placing some good bets
was good bets on the machine are inside
on the machine learning side yeah and
they're often about what about what not
to do rather than what to do
so at the very beginning of the project
we knew we wanted to solve a game a hard
game we didn't know exactly which one we
wanted to do because these are you know
great test beds for pushing the limits
of our algorithms and that one of the
great things about engines to be clear
you guys are two of the key people the
entire team was like ten people the
density about ten people and you know
these things
good test beds for algorithms see what
the limits are to really push the limit
of what's possible and you know for sure
that when you've done it that you've
done it it's the very binary testable
and
so actually the way that we selected the
game was we went on Twitch and just
looked down the list of most popular
games in the world and starting you know
number one is League of Legends I'm the
thing about League of Legends is it
doesn't run on Linux and it doesn't have
a game API and little things like that
actually are the biggest barrier to
making AI progress in odd ways and so
looking down the list dota actually I
was the first one that kind of had all
the right properties runs on Linux that
it has a big community around replayed
parsing that there's a built-in Lua API
it's actually this API was meant for
script for building mods rather than for
building BOTS and we were like but we
could probably use it to build BOTS and
the the you know one of it one of the
great things about valve as a company is
that they're very into you having these
open hackable games where people can go
and do a bunch of custom things and so
kind of philosophically that it was it
was very much the right kind of company
to be working to be working with and so
the we actually did this initial
selection back in November and we're
working in some other projects at the
time and so it didn't really get started
until until late in December and one of
the funny things is that by total
coincidence in mid-december valve
released a new bot focused API and that
they were saying hey our BOTS are
famously bad that maybe the community
can solve this problem so we'll actually
build an API specific for it for people
to do this and that was just one of
those coincidences of the universe that
just worked out extremely well um so we
weren't kind of in close contact with
the developer of this API and I kind of
all throughout so at the very end the
project well what are you gonna do right
and so the first thing was we had to
become very familiar with this game API
to make sure we understood all the
little semantics and you know all the
all of the different different corner
cases and also to make sure that we
could run this thing a large-scale and
to turn it into a pleasant development
environment and so at the time it was
just two of us one person was working
with the body API building a scripted
bot and so basically this is the learn
all the game rules think really hard
about how it works
this particular person who wrote it ROFL
um has I played about three or four
games of dota in his life but he's
watched over a thousand hours of dota
gameplay and has now written the best
the best dota scripted bought in the
world and as that you know sort of a lot
of just writing this thing in Lua
getting very intimately familiar with
all those details in the meanwhile but I
was working on was trying to figure out
how do you turn this thing into a docker
container and so they had this whole
build process turns out that steam can
only be an offline mode for two weeks at
a time that they push new patches all
the times you needed to go from this
like you know sort of manually download
the game and whatever to actually how
in automated repeatable process it turns
out that it's the full game files are
about 17 gigabytes and that our docker
registry can only support 5 gigabyte
layers and so I had to write a thing too
chunk up things into 5 gigabyte tar
balls and put those in s3 and set them
back down so a bunch of sort of like
things there was really just about
figuring out what the right workflow is
what the right abstractions are and then
the next step was well we know we want
to be writing our BOTS and tensorflow
and Python how do you how do you get
that
so why was that well because so machine
learning you know that is actually quite
interesting that a lot of the highest
order bit on progress just like having
the game API is hired orbit it's also
can you use tools that are familiar and
sort of easy to iterate with before the
world of kind of modern machine learning
framework except for right there their
code in MATLAB if you had a new idea
take you two months to do it like good
good luck making progress
yeah and so it was really all about
iteration speed and so if you can get
into the Python world well we have these
large code bases that we built up of
high quality algorithms that there's
just so much cool and built around it
that that's like the optimal experience
and so the next step was to port the
scripted bot into Python and so the way
I did that was I literally just renamed
all of the Lua files to dot PI commented
out the code and then started
uncommenting function by function and
then you know you run the function you
get an exception you then go and
uncomment whatever code it depends on
and as mechanically as possible I tried
to be like a human transpiler and you
know that Lua as one index Python zero
index you have to do that that Lua has
doesn't distinguish between an array
type in it and a dictionary type and so
you kinda have to simply QA those two
but for the most part it is something
that could have been like sort of
totally mechanically done and it's great
because I didn't have to understand any
of the game logic I didn't have to
understand anything that was going on
under the hood I could basically just
pour it over and and it just kind of it
just kind of came together but then you
end up with a small set of functions
that you do not have implementations of
which are although the actual API calls
and so I ended up with a file with a
bunch of dummy calls and I knew exactly
which calls I needed and then
implemented on top of GRP see a pretty
buff based protocol where I on every
tick the game would dump the full game
state send the differ the wire
reassemble that into an in-memory state
object Python and then all of these API
methods would be implemented in Python
and so at the end of this you know it
sounds like a bit of a Frankenstein
process but it actually worked really
well and in the end we had something
that looked just like a typical opening
I'd gym environment and so all you have
to do is you say Jim make this you know
dota environment ID and suddenly you're
playing dota and that your Python code
just has to call into some some you know
object that implements the the glue API
and suddenly these characters are
running around the screen doing what you
want and so this was like a lot of the
kind of thing that that I was working on
to the pure engineering side and
actually you know kind of I went on so
shamone and yeah cup and and J and if
and others going the project and most
people were building on top of this API
and really didn't have to dig into any
of the underlying implementation details
um you know so personally my one machine
learning contribution to the project
I'll tell you about that because you
know my background is primarily startup
engineering building building large
infrastructure not sort of machine
learning definitely not a machine
learning PhD I didn't even finish
college so I kind of reached a point
where I got in the infrastructure into a
pretty stable point that I felt like all
right like I don't have to be fighting
the fires they're very constantly I have
some time to actually focus on digging
some the machine learning one particular
piece that we were interested in doing
was behavioral cloning so we had one at
one of the systems that we had built was
to go and download all of the replays
that are published each day and so the
way this game works is that there's
about 1.5 million replay is that are
available for public download i'm valve
clears and not after two weeks and so
you have to have some discovery process
you have to stick him in s3 somewhere
originally we were downloading all of
them every day and realize that was
about two terabytes worth of data a day
that adds up quite quickly so we ended
up filtering down to the sort most
expert players but we wanted to actually
take this data parse it and use it to
clone the behavior for a bot and so I
spend a lot of time with like sort of
you know it's basically this you have
this whole pipeline to download the
replays to parse them to makind of
iterate on that then take a train a
model and
try to try to predict what the behavior
would be and you know first it's just
like like one thing I find very
interesting is the sort of different
workflow that you end up with when doing
machine learning like they're a bunch of
things where when software engineers
join open AI that are just very
surprising for example if you look at a
typical and research workflow you'll see
a lot of files named like you know
experiment I what if the excitement
experiment is one two three four and you
look at them and they're just like
slight Forks of the same thing and
you're like is this what version
controls employ that and after doing
this this this cloning project I learned
exactly why because the thing is if you
have a new idea for okay well I've kind
of got this thing working and now I'm
gonna try something slightly different
as you're doing the new thing well
machine learning is something very
binary that this at the start it just
like doesn't work at all and you don't
know why or it kind of works but it has
some weird performance and you're not
sure exactly is it a bug is it just how
this dataset works like you just don't
know and so if you've gotten it working
at all and then you make a change you're
always gonna want to go back and kind of
compare to the previous thing you've had
running and so you actually do want the
new thing running side by side with the
old thing and if you're constantly
stashing it on stashing and checking out
whatever then you're just gonna be sad
and and there are a lot of like kind of
workflow issues like that then you just
you got a bang your head against the
wall and then you see like oh I've been
enlightened so before we progress
further on the story um can you just
explain the basics of training a bot in
a game like how are you actually giving
it the feedback so that what that means
it's it's no rocket science even though
like reinforcement learning so fancy
like essentially what's happening is we
have a bot which observed some state in
the environment and perform some actions
based on that slide and based on those
actions that it executes then it
continues playing and eventually you
know either that's well or poorly so
that can that's something that we can
quantify in a number and that's more of
an engineering problem than research
problem how to quantify how good the
body is doing I need to come up so
metric
and then you know the world gets
feedback or whether it is doing good or
not and then tries to select the actions
that yield to hi that positive feedback
the high reward hey and to give us a
sense for how well that works at the bot
plays against itself to get better once
you had everything working how good
would put bot from day and do against a
bot from day and -1 so I guess we have a
story that kind of illustrates what to
expect from from those techniques so
when you said this project our goal
wasn't to really do research I mean at
some high level it was but but we are
very goal-oriented all we wanted to do
is we want to solve problem right we
want to solve that I fight if I have any
other mice love that I want vo and the
way it started it was like everyday
Sanders just clicking Rafa and Rafa was
in parenting scripted bots so he just
like reach I write the logic I think
this is what both should do well he says
he's a creep he nisa I thought I could
yeah they are and he spent like three
months of his time and Rafa is actually
a really good engineer so we had a
really good script that what so so what
happened then you know we kind of like
he got to the point I which improve it
much more so we tried ok let's try
something first first Larry and you know
I I was actually at vacation at the time
but there was other engineer coupe who
throughout my vacation which I found
super surprised I believe there is
nothing I come back this is the
reinforcement learning pod and actually
it's beating our scripted but after like
week worth of engineering effort
possibly those two weeks but but it's
just something very miniature compared
to the development I scripted but so so
actually our body which didn't have any
assumptions baked about the game figured
out that under like game structure well
enough to beat anything that we could
cut my hand which which was pretty
amazing to see and at what point do you
decide to compete in the tournament oh
well so I maybe I should finish up my
story sorry was running a bit long but
it's good I will get good shortly so
just just finish up my machine learning
contribution so I basically spent about
a month really learning the workflow got
something that like I was able to to do
some signs of life where
like run to the middle in your kaha
knows what it's doing it's so good and
it's very clear like when you're just
doing cloning that like these these
algorithms like learn to imitate what it
sees rather than the actual intent and
so it get kind of confused and really
like kind of run you know try to try to
do some sort of like creep blocking or
something but like the creeps wouldn't
be around and so I just feel like he's
exactly back and forth and anyway I got
this to the point where it was actually
creep blocking pretty reliably pretty
well and and then at that point I turned
it over to Jay who was also working on
the project and he used reinforcement
learning to fine-tune that and so
suddenly it went from only understanding
the actions rather than the intent to
suddenly it really knew what it was
doing and it kind of has the best greet
block that anyone has seen and that was
that was my one machine learning
contribution in the project so time went
on and one of the most important parts
of the project was having a scoreboard
so we had a metric on the wall which was
the true scale of our best bot so true
skills basically can evil like rating
that measures the win rate of your bots
versus versus others and you put that on
the wall and each week people just try
all the ideas and some of them work some
of them improve the performance and that
we actually ended up with this very
smooth almost linear curve so we posted
in a blog post and that that really
means kind of like exponential increase
in the strength of the spot overtime and
that part of that is you know sometimes
these data points were you just train
the same experiment for longer I mean
you know typically our experiments last
for maybe up to two weeks but also a lot
of those were while we had a new idea we
tried something else you know we made
this tweak we added this feature remove
this this this other component that
wasn't necessary and so we knew that so
we chose that the the goal of 1v1 I
don't recall exactly when but it must
have been you know in the spring or
maybe maybe even early summer and but we
really didn't know are we actually gonna
be able to make it and you know unlike
normally when you're building an
engineering system you think really hard
about all the components it's like well
you decompose it into this subsystem
that subsystem that subsystem and you
can measure your progress as what
percent of the components are built here
you really have ideas that you need to
try out and that I it's sort of
unpredictable in some sense and actually
one of the most important changes to the
project and are making progress was
initially the way that
management was happening was that each
week well so we'd written down our
milestones if let's beat this person by
this date let's beat this other person
may this state let's you know be able to
do you know kind of these these outcome
based milestones I'm kind of a weekly or
bi-weekly basis it's it I you know those
things would come and go and you
wouldn't have them and then what are you
supposed to do it's completely unnatural
right it's like yeah it's not like there
was anything else you could have done
it's just you have more ideas you need
to try and instead of shifting it to
what are all the things were gonna try
by next week that's a good insight and
then you do that and then yeah if you
didn't actually do everything you said
you're gonna do then you should feel bad
and then you should do more of it and if
you did all those and like it didn't
work then you know fair enough but you
achieve what you want to do to achieve
and so even going into the International
so I two weeks before the International
was kind of our cutoff for at this point
there's not much more we can do that
we're going to do our biggest experiment
ever put all of our compute into one
basket and see see where it goes and and
at that point like it two weeks out how
good was the bottle oh it was badly
sometimes we need with professionals
that we had testing but not not even
always know it sometimes happened so yes
yes it to be specific I'm just pulling
this back in so July 8th is when we had
a first win against our semi-pro tester
and then and then we were kind of more
consistent with it and then he went on
vacation and so he was on some laptop
somewhere that was not very good and
then we were consistently beating him
but that was not very reliable data this
was the week before the International
and so we didn't really know how good we
were getting we knew that the screws go
was going up when was the last time that
like an opening I employee beat the bots
how far out was that from I think like
the I we're not very good at dota okay
but so like a month or two out it could
beat all the open AI people two weeks
out it could at one time beat a semi-pro
I'd say so support four weeks was the
other first the first time that it beat
the semi-pro okay
and then you know two weeks out we don't
know we still can't really find out I
mean I guess we could rerun that but yet
you know we really didn't know how good
it was at that time we just knew hey
we're able to be our semi-pro
occasionally and we going into into the
International figure that hey there's a
50/50 shot and I think we were telling
Sam the whole way like I you know the
probability with these things you never
really trust the probabilities you just
trust the trend of the probabilities
even that was just swinging wildly you
guys had text me every night of a bo
we're gonna you know no chance we're not
going oh we're definitely won every game
yeah yep and so it was very clear there
are own estimates of of what was gonna
happen were miscalibrated
and and throughout the the week of Ti
actually we still didn't know and what
was happening you guys all went to
Seattle for this week most of the team
went okay yes so you're like holed up in
a hotel or a conference center or
something
well actually the reality of it was that
we were holed up like near near the
stadium event was happening let me
describe how we were holed up so we were
given a locker room in the basement of
Key Arena so we all had production
badges and so you can feel very special
as you walk in years ago yeah you know I
just said to get to you know kind of go
skip the line and and go to the
backstage area but it was literally a
locker room they converted into a
filming area and we all had our laptops
in there and that they would also bring
in pro players every so often we had a
whole filming set up and and then we
play against the pros and we had we had
a partition that we set up which was
just like a like a black cloth basically
between like the whole team sitting
there being like are we gonna be able to
beat this bro maybe and trying to guys
quite as possible and these you know
these pros who were playing and you know
on Monday they brought three or I think
two pros and like one very high ranked
analyst buy and we had our first game
and you know we really didn't know what
was gonna happen and we beat this person
three three zero and you know this was
actually a very exciting thing for
everyone at opening eyewear so at the
time what I was I was kind of live live
slacking the updates as the game is like
this person you know just said this and
like I'm with that
like you know now it's this many last
hit and yeah were you winning by a large
margin so yet you remember the details
of that one let's oblate sacked what the
margin was I mean we have all the data
but valve brought in the second Pro this
this professional named pyke at and he
played the bot and we beat him once we
beat him twice and then he beat us oh
okay and that I we looking at the game
we knew exactly what had happened yeah
yeah essentially what happened is he
accumulated a bunch of want charges
right is this item that accumulate
strategist and he accumulated more
charges than our what has ever seen it
again because just our BOTS the the
don't it turns out that like there was a
small I think it's safe to say the kind
of a bag in DotA eaten in our setup okay
so basically some threshold that your
bot was not ready for well I'd say very
very specifically the kind of root cause
here was that he had gone for an item in
early wand build okay and we had just
never done item early wand build and so
it's just like our bot had just never
seen this particular item build before
okay and so it never had a chance to
really explore what does it mean like
and so it had never learned to save up
stick charges and to use them and
whatever and so that it would do is very
good at calculating like who's gonna win
at fight wild collide because in my
garden recognize that he's like I wonder
what happens if I push on this axis and
sure enough it was an axis the bot
hadn't seen and so then we played a
third we played a third match against
another pro went 3-0 on that it's
actually very interesting getting the
pros reaction because we also didn't
really know the kind of fun it's gonna
be cool or they hate it yeah and we got
we got a mix of reactions you know
something some of the pros are like this
is the coolest thing ever I want to
learn more about it one of the pros like
this thing's stupid I would never use it
but apparently my after the pros left
that night they spent four hours just
like talking about the bots and kind of
what what it meant yeah the flavors were
like highly emotional in their reactions
to the but they were never beaten by the
computer so this kind of unbelievable so
for example
one of the players I actually managed to
eventually beat the but he was like okay
this this body I think use less like I
have never want to see and then he kind
of called down and like after like five
or ten minutes he's like okay this is
actually great this is gonna improve my
practice a lot on and so after your
bought it lost that first time did they
start talking about counterintuitive
strategies to beat it alright well so so
I think at that point um that you know I
think that maybe you can you answer that
yes I don't think pro players are
interested in that the pro players are
mostly interested in the aspect where
they it lets them get better at the game
which which means that but but there was
a point after the event where we set up
this big LAN party where we had like 50
computers running the world you kind of
unleashed this form of humans that our
vote and they find found all the
exploits and we kind of expected them to
be there because the ball can only learn
as well as the environment in which it
plays allows it to write so there are
some things that you just never seen and
of course those those those ones will be
exploitable and we are kind of excited
about our you know our next step which
is 5 by 5 because 585 is one giant
exploit like essentially it's it's about
like exploiting the other team like
being where they don't expect you to be
kind of like the doing other division
things so so naturally we know we will
have to solve those problems head-on for
5v5 right so one thing I think it was
pretty interesting about the training
process is that a lot of our job while
we were doing this was seeing what the
exploits were and then making a small
tweak that fixes them and like the way
that that I now think about machine
learning systems is that they're they're
really a way to make the leverage of
human programmers go way up okay
right cuz again normally like when
you're building a system you build
component one component to component
three and that kind of your marginal
return on like building component for is
like you know similar to your margin on
the return on component 1 whereas here a
lot of the early stuff that we did it's
just like your thing goes from being
like crappy to like slightly less crappy
but once we're at the International and
we had this loss to PI cat we knew
okay well the root cause here is just
it's never seen this item build before
well all we had to do was make it tweak
hmmm to add that to our list of item
builds and then it played out this
scenario for the next you know however
long okay can you walk me through
actually how that tweak works on the
technical side because my impression is
kind of what you guys have been saying
it's just been in a million games so it
kind of has learned all this stuff and
some people talk about you know these
networks it's just very gray and they
don't actually know how to manipulate
what how are you guys getting in there
and changing things yes so it's kind of
a some sense on the high level you can
compare this purse to teaching a human
like you know you know like kind of you
see a kid doing maths and it's kind of
like confusing like addition with
subtraction stuff I was right I need I
can like look here this symbol this is
this is this is what you're not seeing
clearly right and and and the same of
those weeks did so clearly our bot has
never seen this one built that that Greg
correctly mentioned and you know all we
had to do is we had to say that like
when you when the bot plays games and
chooses what items to purchase we just
need to add some probability of sampling
that specific build that it has never
seen and when it plays a couple of games
against opponents that use that build
when it uses this build a couple of
times itself then then it kind of
becomes more comfortable with the idea
of what happens what what are the
in-game consequences of that build okay
and kind of a day so I've kind of a
couple couple different levels that
answer I think are pretty interesting so
one is at a you know very like kind of
object level so the way that these
models work is you basically do have a
black box which takes in some lists of
numbers and outputs a list of numbers
mm-hmm and you know it's very smart and
how it does that mapping but that's what
you get
yeah and then you think of this is this
is my primitive now what do I build on
top of that so that as little work as
possible has to be done inside of the
learning here and a lot of your job is
well one thing that we noticed that we'd
forgotten as well on Monday was well it
wasn't we'd forgot
I just hadn't got around to it was I the
passing in data that corresponds to the
person I was passing in the visibility
of a teleport know as a human you can
see when someone's teleporting out our
BOTS just did not have that feature that
list of numbers passed in did not have
that feature and so well one of the
things you need to do is you just need
to add it and so that kind of goes from
your feature is you know your future
vectors however long that was and now
it's got one more one more feature on
and the bot wasn't recognizing that as
an on-screen thing so it doesn't see the
screen it's passed data from the bot a P
i okay
and so it really is given whatever data
we give it okay and so it's kind of on
us to do some of this feature
engineering and you want to do as much
as you can to make it as easy as
possible so that it has to do as little
work inside as possible so it can spend
you know you think of it as you get some
fixed capacity do you want to spend that
on learning the strategy do you want to
spend it on learning how to like you
know map you know choose which creep you
want to hit like you want to spend that
on trying to parse pixels like you know
that the at the end of the day that I
think a lot of our job as the the system
designers here is to push as much of
that model capacity as much of the
learning towards their like interesting
parts of the problem that you can't
script that you can't possibly do any
processing for and so that's kind of
that's kind of one one level is that a
lot of the work ends up being
identifying which features aren't there
we're kind of engineering the the
observation action spaces in an
appropriate way another thing is I think
is like another level resume out is like
the way that this actually happened was
so you know we're there on Monday and
people got dinner and then Ramon and
yeah cup and Raul and I inside and I
think you know maybe one or two others
stayed up all night to do surgery on our
running experiment okay and so it was
very much like a you've got your
production outage and like everyone's
there like all hands on deck trying to
go and and and and make the improvements
yeah so specifically like to kind of
zoom in and give you a bit of fear well
what what this felt like what working on
the world like you know like this is
like very tiring week every day we were
like the day was just like meeting with
the pros and can what you go about
getting excited and the nice were kind
of coding up the next version of
experiment because actually it's a
but from day-to-day like iteration of
the experiment was not good enough to
beat the next player next next days
professional so just that warning to
download the new parameters of the the
network and it would be good enough to
beat it but the day before it wasn't
how are you discerning that was again
something of almost a coincidence I mean
yeah there might be something a little
bit deeper but so the you know kind of
full full story the week was we did the
Monday play okay and that you know there
we lost your pocket and so Justin just
to clarify are you guys in the
competition or not in the competition so
the the thing that we did was we did a
special event okay to play against Dendi
who's you know one of the one of the
best players of all time and while we
were there that we were also like well
let's test this out against all these
other pros gotcha physically here right
now and okay let's see how we do got it
all right so Monday happens you start
training it but yep and so so so
actually so yeah so this experiment
we've kicked off you know maybe
sometimes the prior week you know and
weeks before things yes something like
that and that we've been running this
experiment for a while and our
infrastructure is really meant for you
run an experiment from scratch you know
you start from complete randomness and
then and then you run it and then you
you two weeks later go and see how it
does we didn't have two weeks anymore
and so we had to do this surgery and
this very careful like you know read
every single character of your commit to
make sure that you're not gonna have any
bugs because if you mess it up we're out
of time there's nothing you can do it's
not one of those things like if you're
just a little bit more clever that you
can you know go and do a hot patch and
have everything be good it's just
literally the case that you gotta let
this thing sit here it's got to bake
yeah and so Monday came and went we were
running this this this experiment that
we perform surgery on and the next day
we got a little bit of reprieve where we
just played against some some kind of
lower ranked players who you know kind
of commentators and popular in the
community but you know we're not pushing
the limit of our bots on Wednesday at
1:00 p.m. our contact from for valve
came by and said hey I'm gonna get you
RTZ and sumail who are basically you
know the top players in the world and I
was like could we push them off to
Thursday maybe and he was like their
schedules books
you're gonna get them when you get them
and that we're gonna we were scheduled
to get them at 4:00 p.m. okay so we
looked at our bot to see how it was
doing and we kind of been along the way
gauging it we tested it against our semi
pro player and he said this broad bot is
completely broken oh no and you know
kind of pictures of maybe we had a bug
during the surgery go like went through
our head and he showed us the issue he
said look first wave the spot takes a
bunch of damage it doesn't have to take
there's no advantage to that I'm gonna
run it I'm gonna go kill it I'll show
you how easy it is he ran it to kill it
and he lost okay and don't jump ahead
explain what happened so so he played it
five times and he lost each time until
he finally did figure out how to exploit
it and we realized what was going on was
that this bot had learned a strategy of
baiting you pretend to be a really dumb
boy you don't know what you're doing and
then when the person comes in to kill
you you just turn around you go super
bot it was legitimately a bad strategy
you know if you're really really good
but I guess it was good against the
whole population of BOTS that it was
playing against and you had never seen
it until that day so we expected it was
like one of the major example one of the
major examples of the things that we
kind of didn't have explicitly incentive
for and yet they both actually learned
them and yeah essentially I mean the
this this just kind of funny because of
course when they both played against its
other versions it was just like good
fighting strategy I was kind of other
division but if you got a very
interesting psychological effect on
humans because after you our strategy
was not to fall for the way it was kind
of to wait it out a little bit because
the voter IDs are the disadvantage but
he's like okay look up stupidest buddies
I'm gonna go for a kill so it kind of
had interesting psychological effect on
humans which I thought was like its kind
it almost knows it's a bot
yeah it knows how its attacked yeah you
know it's funny to see a vote which kind
of seems like it's playing with emotions
of the here of course it was not what
actually happened but it seemed this way
so now so now we were faced with the
dilemma it's 1:00 p.m. on Wednesday
that these best players are going to
show them up at 4 p.m. we have a broken
bot what are we gonna do and we know
that our Monday bot is not gonna be good
enough we know it's not going to cut it
and so the first thing we do is we write
well Monday but it is pretty good at the
first wave this new bot is a super bot
thereafter okay so can we stitch the two
together so we wrote so so we already we
had some code for doing something
similar mama so we kind of revived that
and then in the three hours J's spent
his time doing a very careful stitch
where you run the first spot and then
you cut over at the right time to the
second bot and and this is literally
just like bot one plays the first is
amount of time and then literally just
that and he finished it 20 minutes
before the course before the granite
buyer semi pro Santa Cruz like this is
great so at least we got that done in
the nick of time but the other question
was how do we actually fix the spot and
I mean I actually just finished like one
aspect because we were also kind of
uncertain what happens when you switch
over from one boat to the other so I was
actually standing by the the pro who was
playing it and I was looking at the time
at the moment when when it was switching
I was like yeah and of course it was
probably completely unnecessary but but
we weren't sure what would happen there
so I didn't know about that part of the
story
so the question of how do you actually
fix it so there was a little bit of
debate of like maybe we should abandon
ship on this switch back to our old
experiment run that one for longer and I
forget I forget who suggested it but
someone's like I think we just have to
let it run for longer because you learn
a strategy of baiting well the counter
strategy for that is just don't bait mm
okay well the whole time and so we got
that run for the additional three hours
and so we first played our T Z who
showed up on our switch bot you know
kind of the Franken bot and you know
that beat him three times and read all
right let's try out this other bot and
just see what happened with the
additional three hours of training
because you know our semi-pro tester at
least validated that like it looks like
it's fixed and so in that three hours of
training how many games is it actually
playing simultaneously that's a good
question quite a bit yeah okay
and and so we we played this new bot
against our T's II didn't know how I was
gonna do and sure enough it beats him
and and he loved it he was having a lot
of fun he ended up getting loving games
that day and I remember maybe was ten
but I think that he's just like all this
is so cool we were supposed to have
sumail that day as well but due to a
scheduling snafu he had to be at some
panel and so like time he didn't work
out but arteezy and in his coach who
also coaches sumail
both said there's a yeah both said suma
house gonna beat this bot like it's
gonna happen you know maybe he'll have a
little bit trouble to figure it out for
the first game but like after that
you're in trouble
and so I all right we've got one more
day to figure out what to do and so what
do we do for some nice dinner we we kind
of rested kind of you know like no slack
with some people at home and then in the
morning we download the new parameters
of the network and just let it play so
we hung out and just let it go just let
it play it's the exact opposite of how
I'm used to engineering deadlines
happening yeah normally it's your work
right up until the minute so you guys
wanted like you guys were getting like
full night's of sleep nice and relaxed
no no absolutely not okay so I don't
like this clear the night before the
night we found that like two nights
before the day where we got the rest
relaxation the night look something like
the following had like we had full day
of dealing with the problems and kind of
like emotional highs and sauce is
absolutely knackered come midnight we
start working okay we need to make all
those changes like the one thing that we
talked about around midnight we start
with four people and we are all so tired
that like you know we look through all
the comments that we are gonna add to
the experiments there are actually two
people looking at them because we didn't
trust a single person given how tired we
are we are so they're like looking at
those constants 6:00 a.m. as I was doing
this like updating the model which is a
lot of nasty like off-by-one
indexing things even though it is a
short call it took me like six hours six
hours to the
somewhere around 3 a.m. we had like a
phone call either because it turns out a
certain number of machines start
exceeding some limits we try to make
them raise the limits and around 6 a.m.
we are okay we are ready to deploy this
and then there was the flying is just
like one-man job so
yak-yak was was was just like you know
he thinking like you know clicking the
deploy and and kind of fixing all the
issues that came up I was staying around
just exclusively to make sure that the a
coop doesn't fall asleep and eventually
at 11 a.m. the experiment was running
and we kind of went to sleep like woke
up at 4 p.m. or something it was like so
it had it had over 24 hours to Train I
think I think I ended up being like
one-and-a-half they until the game of
sorry yeah just repeat the timeline so
this was Monday
who's when we played first set of games
had the loss did the surgery that night
you know it's played it I guess starting
on 11 on Tuesday then yeah Wednesday 4
p.m. is when we played our TZ and then
train for longer I don't think we made
any changes after that maybe we made
some small ones all right but I'm then
on Thursdays when we played sumail okay
and so I think Tuesday to Wednesday was
the night we've made less changes yeah
and there was like quite quite a bit
like it's it's it's you know there's
quite a bit of different work going on
that all kind of came together at once
like one thing I think it was really
important was I so we went one of our
team members his handle of SCI ho who's
very well known program programming
competition I competitor was spending a
lot of time just watching the bot play
and seeing why does it do this weird
thing in this case you know what are all
of a like you know weird tweaks and
really getting intuitions for oh because
we're representing this feature in this
way and so if we change it to this other
thing and it's gonna work in a different
way and I think that like this really
trying to it's almost as very human like
process of watching this like expert
playing the game and try to figure out
what are all the little micro decisions
that are go
into this macro choice and it's kind of
interesting starting to have this very
different relationship to the system you
build because normally the way that you
do it as well your goal is to have
everything be very observable and so
yeah you want to put metrics on
everything and like you know that if
something's not understandable add more
logging like you know that that's that's
how you design the systems whereas here
you have this you know you do have that
for the surrounding bits but for this
machine learning core that there you
really do have to understand it at more
of a sort of behavioral level was it
ever stumping you where you're just like
that's being creative in a way that we
didn't expect it to and it may be even
working but you don't know why or how it
decided to make that choice few small
ones like where you know there's like
some early days of the project where
we're like we have professionals like
playing the next iteration of the father
he's like yeah both is really good at
creeping and we are like there is also
one one other part of the story that I
think is interesting and then I think
probably we can we can wrap up this part
but uh so to see how well I you know we
are semi-pro test here I'd played
hundreds of games against this spot over
the past you know a couple months and so
we wanted to see just how does he
benchmark relative start easy and so we
had him play against RTZ and you know
Artesia was up the whole game
he was just like beating him to the last
hit by 500 milliseconds every single
time and so our semi-pro I was like all
right I've got one last-ditch effort to
go try this strategy that the bots
always does to me and it's like some
some you know strategy where you I do
something complicated and then you like
triple wave the your opponent you get
him out of the tower you have regen you
don't need to go in for the kill and he
did it and it worked
whoa and this was the the bots had like
taught him the strategy that you could
use against human and I think that was
like very interesting and a good example
of the kinds of things that you can get
out of these systems that they can
discover these very sort of you know
non-obvious strategies that can actually
be taught to humans and how did it go a
smell so with smell we we we went
undefeated I
and I think it was 5-0 that day one
thing that's actually interesting so
we'll probably blog about this in
upcoming weeks but we've actually been
playing against a bunch of pros since
then so we it's our pot has been very
high demand and some of these pros have
been live streaming it and so we've
gotten a better sense of of kind of
watching as humans go from you know just
being completely unable to beat it - if
you play against it for long enough you
can actually get pretty good
and so I there's actually a very
interesting I I you know a set of stats
there that you know will be I kind of
pulling and analyzing in a bit
are there humans that consistently beat
the bots today yeah so I think there's
one who is like a 20% win rate or
something and that player played games
and just finds strategies to exploit no
actually he becomes essentially as good
as the board really at what the bodies
they find extremely surprising but it
turns out that he played hanket's of
games of it so it's actually and you see
a top player like this he be at most
humans are all professionals okay like
it's not just some random kid who's good
at beating the bot that's right like the
way the way to think about this is that
like yeah I mean the game professional
video game player is pretty high bar
yeah I think ever wants to be a
professional video game player if you
know who play these games and the number
of pros is very small and there are some
who I have really liked you know and
you're playing hundreds of games against
it you're gonna you're gonna get very
very good at the things that it does and
so talking to our tz1
I was asking him has a changed your play
style at all and he said he thinks that
the thing it's done for him is it's
helped him focus more um because like
you know while you're just there in Lane
last-hitting now suddenly like that's
just so rude right because you just have
been doing it so much you've gotten so
good at it and I think that one really
interesting thing to see is gonna be how
can you improve can you improve human
play style
can you change human play style and I
think that we're starting to see some
positive answers in that direction so I
know we're almost out of time I could do
like a little lightning around just
quickly go through special yes actually
like to the question of like what kind
of skills you need to work out of and I
do you have like a very small that was
gonna be the first lightning round
question so specific list of things that
that we found very useful at least in in
the data team is some knowledge of
distributed systems because we build a
lot of those and those are easy to not
do properly and another thing that that
we found very important is actually
writing back free code essentially
essentially I know it's kind of taken
for granted in computer science
community that like everybody makes bugs
and so on but here it's even more
important other projects that you
minimize it because they're very hard to
debug specifically many bugs manifest in
kind of lower training performance where
to get that number it takes a day and in
like a spree of hungies of convinces
it's really easy to miss so and primary
way of debugging this is actually
reading the code so every bug has very
high cost associated with it so so
actually writing like this correct
bug-free code is quite important to us
and we sometimes actually kind of
sacrifice good engineering Cabot's good
good kind of code modularity to make our
code shorter and simpler and kind of
having glass essentially less lines
where you can make bugs and I guess
lastly as much like primary skills good
engineering but if somebody really feels
like gosh I really need to brush up my
maps like I really need to kind of go in
there and feel comfortable like not have
like somebody asked me a question about
master day and send that and I think
mostly like getting good basics in
linear algebra in linear algebra and in
in basic statistics that's especially
when doing experiments it's easy to make
like elementary statistics mistakes and
and and linear algebra is just kind of
most of what you need to know too
like basic optimization as well to
follow what's what's happening in those
models but but this is kind of compared
to being a good engineer quite easy to
pick up at least in project like the one
we're doing yeah I wanted to talk about
some non-technical skills that I think
are really important um so one is I that
I think that there's like a real
humility that's required if you're
coming from an engineering background
like I am I am working working in these
these projects where you're you're no
longer the technical expert in the way
that you're used to right I think that
you know if you go when you build you
talk to you talk to like you know you
listen you want to build a product for
doctors where I think you can talk to
ten doctors and honestly whatever thing
you're going to build is probably going
to be a pretty valuable addition to
their workflow because doctors can't
really build their own software tools
you know some can but you know in a
general world know whereas with machine
learning research you know everyone that
you're working with is very technical
can build their own tools but if you
inject engineering discipline in the
right place if you build the right tool
at the right time if you kind of look at
the workflow and think about oh we could
do it in this other way that's where you
can really add a bunch of value and so I
think it's about knowing when to inject
the engineering discipline but also
knowing when not to and being you know
to Sherman's point sometimes well we
really just want the really short code
because we're really terrified of bugs
and and so that can yield different
choices than you might expect for
something that's just a peer production
says who writes the least bugs to all
open AI oh that's a contentious question
who writes the least bugs per line of
code at all of opening I I'm deaf I'm
not gonna say me yeah yeah it's three I
could the Ark of the least amount of
times in black so it's more okay to have
bugs that are gonna cause exception
right in my bugs usually cause
experience so that's fine that's fine
yeah it's what you don't want is the
things that cause correctness issues
where it gets 10% worse yeah so there
was another question related to skills
but this is for non-technical people
yeah so Tim Beco asks how can
non-technical people be helpful to AI
star
well I was gonna say I think I think one
important thing is that for AI generally
right now I think there's a lot of noise
and I think it could be hard to
distinguish what is real from what's not
I think just like simply educating
yourself I think is like a pretty
important thing like I think it's very
clear that AI is gonna have a pretty big
impact and you know that's just look at
what's already being created and
extrapolate that without any new
technology development any new research
and it's pretty clear there's gonna be
baked into lots of different systems
there are a lot of ethical issues to
work through and I think that being kind
of a voice in those conversations and
educating yourself I think is like a
really important thing and then you look
to well what are we gonna be able to
develop next and I think that that's
where the really transformative stuff is
gonna come okay I once saw a post in
Greg's rescue time report it was pretty
shocked to have any advice for work
views for working such long hours I
think it's not a good goal I would not
have a goal of trying to maximize the
number of hours you sit at your computer
for me I do it because I love it and
that the thing that the activity that I
love most in the world is when you're in
the zone writing code producing it for
something that's meaningful and
worthwhile and so I think that as a
second-order effect it can be good but I
wouldn't say that like that is the way
to have an impact I will also say more
specifically the only way I've ever seen
people be super productive as if they're
doing something they love there is
nothing else that will sustain you over
a long enough period of time okay is the
term AI over used by many startups just
to look good in the press yes okay what
is the last job that will remain as AI
starts to do everything else
the last human job I was gonna be the
hardest thing for ad to do it sir in
general I think it's actually not AI
researcher the guy a researcher will
what kind of go before key it's actually
very interesting when you ask people
this question I think that everyone
tends to say whatever their job is as
well as the hardest one but I actually
think that AI researchers got to be one
that you're gonna want to make these
systems very good it totally
the last question maybe this is obvious
is um can you just connect the dots
between how playing video games is
relevant to building a GI yeah it's
actually maybe one of the most
surprising things to me the degree to
which games end up being used for AI
research and the real thing that you
want right is you really want to have
algorithms that are operating in complex
environments where they can learn skills
and that you want to increase the
complexity of those skills that they
learn and that's either you push the
environment you push the complexity the
algorithms you scale these things up and
if that's really the path that you want
to take to building really powerful
systems so games are great because they
are a prepackaged environment that some
other humans have spent time sort of
making first of all putting in a lot of
complexity making sure that there's like
actual intellectual things to solve
there or not even just intellectual but
you know like interesting mechanical
challenges that you you kind of can get
human level baselines on them so you
know exactly how hard they are that
they're they're very nice unlike you
know something like robotics where you
can just run them entirely virtually and
and that that means you can scale them
up and you can run many copies of them
and so they're a very convenient testbed
and I think what you're gonna see is
that there's a lot of work that's gonna
be done in games but the goal is of
course bring it out of the game and
actually use it to solve problems in the
real world and to actually you know be
able to interact with humans and do
useful things there so I think they're
they're very good sort of starter and a
very good place to like I think one
thing that I really like about this dota
project and bringing it to all these
pros is that we're all going to be
interacting with super advanced AI
systems in the future and right now I
think we don't really have good
intuitions as to how they operate where
they fail what it's like to interact
with them and that this is a very low
stakes way of having your first
interaction with very advanced AI
technology cool if someone wants to get
involved with open AI what should they
do oh well we have a job posting other
website I guess the the tips that is
giving about how to get a job out of
money I are very geared towards a
specific job most thing that we have
there which is a large scaring force and
letting engineer go yeah and in general
we look for people who are
very good at whatever technical access
they specialize in and we can use lots
of different specialties great alright
thanks guys just to echo that like
everyone thinks they have to be in AI
PhD not true neither of these guys are
alright thanks a lot thanks yeah thank
you
you